économie donc à présent et robert
cadalbert président de la communauté
d'agglomération qui est resté sur ce
plateau on va aborder le sujet avec vous
la taxe transport et puis la taxe
professionnelle ou plutôt la taxe qui la
remplace aujourd'hui tout d'abord le
versement transport c'est donc cette
taxe versée par les entreprises aux
communes pour financer les transports
publics puisqu'ils sont réemployés
presse très utilisés par les employés
elle augmente très fortement en 2013
dans plusieurs endroits en france +11 %
à dijon à denis sont à nancy encore à
saint quentin en yvelines est ce qu'il
ya une telle hausse de cette taxe de ce
versement transmis au versement
transport est fixé par la région et donc
effritement les augmentations qu'on peut
avoir sont liés aux investissements de
l'ensemble des transports en commun qui
sont faits sur la région donc il ya une
augmentation en fonction des zones de ce
côté là j'ai pas avec la moyenne je n'ai
pas le chiffre exact de la halle de
l'augmentation mais je sais que elle est
fonction de la zone de la région ile de
france la présidente du medef laurence
parisot qui est très en colère sur cette
hausse elle parle d'augmentation à
considérer le versement transport qui a
augmenté de 50% en 10 ans concrètement
ça sert à quoi ce versement transport et
pourquoi ils augmentent aussi vite c'est
celle essentielle qui finance le
syndicat des transports qui permet à la
sncf et à la ratp de faire effectivement
un système de transport qui est très
performant en ile-de-france par
suffisamment parce qu'on a beaucoup
d'investissement a fait encore et donc
vous savez les usagers ne paye que 30 %
du coût de réel du transport donc il
faut quelqu'un paye d'autres séoul
impôts ou les transports l'habitude des
entrepreneurs c'est lui qui voit cette
taxe augmente et plus de 50% 6 ans c'est
une moyenne nationale mais bien sûr mais
est ce que le service suit voilà est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on répond parce
que ces entreprises ne vivrait pas s'il
y avait pas de transport donc après si
on veut un service de transport
performant il faut bien quelqu'un perd
situation que valeur de crise c'est
compliqué aussi mais il faudra bien que
quelqu'un paye si c'est par l'usagé qui
paye eh ben ça peut être que l'impôt ou
les entreprises qui utilisent ce n'est
il n'y aurait pas de développement des
entreprises s'il n'y avait pas un
système de transport soit pour leur
client soit pour leur personnel donc
c'est normal que tout le monde participe
à cet effort après on peut toujours
calculé savoir c'est plus oh c'est plus
usagers c'est plus l'entreprise il ya
une équipe qui est fait donc à chaque
fois on peut en discuter et au delà de
ce versement transport il ya une autre
taxe qui remplace cette taxe
professionnelle depuis 2010 et la
contribution foncière des entreprises
les entrepreneurs et qui ont reçu il ya
quelques semaines leur avis de règlement
certains ont constaté une hausse de 500%
explication alors ces techniques le
calcul du montant dû par les entreprises
repose sur la valeur locative des biens
des entreprises selon un taux fixé par
les collectivités locales et la valeur
locative n'est pas toujours en rapport
avec l'activité réelle des entreprises
il ya donc un décalage entre ce que les
entreprises peuvent payer ce que ça
représente comme somme quelle est la
situation à 51 en mls que les
entrepreneurs elle s'inquiète de cette
contribution foncière des entreprises
bien sûr qu'il sera quasi normal
simplement on est un système de
changement de loi sur la taxe
professionnelle qui a été supprimée la
suppression arrivé en 2010
malheureusement pour certains le
changement de taxes directes en 2012
donc beaucoup de s'inquiètent de voir
deux ans après alors qu'ils ont plus de
taxe professionnelle voir arriver cette
nouvelle taxe qui est j'appellerais la
taxe a qu un faux ligue 1 clair je faire
une loi qui était complètement injuste
parce que la preuve l appel que
contribution foncière des entreprises
des fois il ya aucun lien avec le
foncier donc on a même des exemples
d'entreprises qui ont simplement une
adresse postale absolument pas de faux
sites et qui sont taxés dessus donc je
comprends l'émoi d'un grand nombre dans
le choc donc l'agglomération ne peut pas
faire d'une loi qui complètement injuste
on va bien et que c'était le changement
de taxe professionnelle tp dans la
provision président de la république
sortant un jour lors des voeux à
l'annoncé c'est la fin de la taxe
professionnelle
tout le monde sait libé comment on fait
donc aujourd'hui c'est pareil
7 milliards 5 d'impôts en moins des
entreprises toi tu es payé par qui m'a
par les ménages ouais hélas une
contribution qu'ils ont accepté que l'on
met en place sur une loi complètement
injuste et donc aujourd'hui on a bien
conscience que cette loi est injuste
enfin pour certains tous les cas que
d'autres contribuent
ça me paraît normal et donc on a demandé
d' une réforme de cette loi elle a été
déjà
voter même si dans le labyrinthe
budgétaire et va être repassé devant
l'assemblée nationale pour avoir une
modification de la loi en se recueillant
sur cet exercice fiscal de cette année
quelles solutions concrètes ils sont à
payer toute façon oui une prise de
contact et si la somme et on a demandé
au ministre de
l'économie des finances de nous donner
les moyens mais aujourd'hui je
proposerai mois une délibération au
conseil du 20 décembre et au bureau de
cette semaine des élus en fonction de ce
que la loi sera modifiée ce que le
mystère ne pourra nous permettre
d'alléger de voir il ya des dénés psy
par exemple les professionnels de santé
là on vient de parler de la
faculté des sciences de la santé on
demande à ces produits santé de ceux de
s'installer sur le territoire et la
première chose qu'on leur fait ce genre
de demandes on leur donne un appeau donc
la plus forte pour les aider à
s'installer peut-être c'est qu un
dégrèvement certaines professions
puisque la mayo tai chi à partir les
sages femmes sont des grès ne paye pas
cette taxe là donc on demande par
exemple que toutes les professions de
santé soient effectivement exagéré on
demande aussi que cette taxe qui est
faite complètement n'importe comment qui
est sûre la le chiffre d'affaires et
vous savez très bien que le chiffre
d'affaires veut pas dire bénéfices donc
il ya des entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires important mais un bénéfice
très très faibles qui se retrouve avec
une taxe beaucoup trop importante et
donc on demande que ce soit sur la
valeur ajoutée de l'entreprise la taxe
avait pour l'instant été fait sur les
verts ajoutent prix jusqu'à 50 millions
de chiffre d'affaires en dessous de 50
millions bah c'est n'importe quoi donc
il y aura des ajustements dès cette
année ont tous comme tout ce que le
gouvernement et tous que la loisne perd
la tête bien sûr le fera pour
effectivement rang essayez d'éviter ces
ces inégalités ces injustices que cette
loi ou fait porter un portugais aux
entreprises merci robert cadalbert
président de la communauté
d'agglomération de saint quentin est
revenu sur ce plateau on veut ouvrir une
page de sport comme chaque lundi anthony
rech va me rejoindre et puisque nous
parlons politique un sujet qui va
forcément vous intéresser elle le
feuilleton à l'ump nouvel épisode ce
soir jean françois copé qui rencontre
françois fillon va-t-il y avoir
référendum va-t-il y avoir de nouvelles
élections et surtout demain à
l'assemblée le rassemblement pour l'ump
le nouveau groupe de l'ancien premier
ministre va-t-il si lg voici la vie de
valérie pécresse député de la 2e
circonscription est très engagé aux
côtés de françois fillon donc je suis
profondément optimiste je crois en la
politique et je pense encore que l'ump
peut sortir par le haut de cette crise à
condition qu'on revote à condition qu'on
redonne la parole aux militants et qu'on
fasse de cet exercice qui pour l'instant
est un exercice raté un exercice réussi
démocratie interne et quand jean
françois copé dit il faut revoter dans
un an et demi est ce que c'est trop long
pour vous il faut que les mutants
revoter vous savez qu'en ce moment même
françois fillon et jean françois copé se
parlent ils sont en train de d'essayer
de trouver une porte de sortie et moi je
les appelle tous les deux vraiment de
tout mon coeur à penser à leurs
militants et demain sur les fondations
nationales vous serez dans quel groupe
je verrai j'espère vraiment que nous
arriverons à trouver une issue d'ici ce
soir moi je crois vraiment que les
hommes de bonne volonté doivent se
parler et qu'on doit réussir à trouver
de solutions